. I used to watch Jeopardy when I was younger.
But I admit it's been decades since I've really
watched Jeopardy. But one of the big things
about Jeopardy under the tutelage of the great
Alex Trebek was that it was just about facts
and empiricism. That's what it was about.
And unfortunately, that's the exact opposite
of pseudoscience pushing Dr. Mehmet Oz.
Mehmet Oz is like a TV. He's a real doctor. He's
there's no he's a real doctor, but he's also
like a TV doctor who appears on different shows,
often giving, giving medical advice. And after the
passing of longtime Jeopardy! Host Alex Trebek,
Jeopardy has tried a number of different guest
hosts. And this week or for a two week period,
actually, the guest host is Dr. Mehmet Oz. To me,
this is pathetically embarrassing. It's yet to
put a in front of a for a show that is supposed
to be about just the facts and empiricism to
put in a guy who for years has been peddling
all sorts of quackery and pseudo science seems
completely antithetical to what Jeopardy is about.
I don't really care in the sense that I don't
even watch this show, but there are tons of
Jeopardy fans who are absolutely furious about
this. And I have to tell you, I actually get it.
I actually get it. Why do you put on a
science doctor to host a show about facts?
A Dr. Oz has previously pushed various weight
loss products, including a green coffee extract,
which is completely and utterly not based in
any kind of science whatsoever. And in fact,
even the claims that the company based their
marketing on have since been retracted. Dr. Oz
has pushed the idea that GMOs are unhealthy. Now,
I know this is on. Popular with some on the left,
there is no scientific evidence that GMOs are
unhealthy by virtue of being GMOs. Yes, there is
overlap between GMOs and pesticides and there are
all sorts of deleterious effects associated with
pesticides. But there is not evidence that GMOs
are unhealthy. I know some of you will get mad and
say, David, but that's not been studied. It has
been studied. Go to scholar Google Dotcom and find
endless, peer reviewed, even long term studies on
GMOs. Dr. Oz has pushed cures for the common cold,
including something called unkillable BARUT
extract. There is no science to back that up.
It can have side effects and Dr. Oz has
pushed it. Dr. Oz has talked about cures
for restless leg syndrome, which include
putting lavender soap under your bed sheets
because the floral smell may be relaxing.
No scientific research supports that claim.
He's talked about, you know, do it yourself.
Teeth whitening methods that involve strawberries.
This is not who should be hosting Jeopardy.
And I'm not arguing for anybody to be canceled.
I don't even care what Jeopardy
does. They can do whatever they want.
But it seems like we actually have a show
here based on empirical knowledge and facts.
And you bring on Dr. Oz. I don't like it. You tell
me if you think I'm right or if I'm wrong or if it
just doesn't really matter. And I shouldn't even
be talking about it on The David Pakman Show.